ton d'emmanuel macro aujourd'hui dans
l'actualité il y avait aussi ce
rassemblement des soutiens d'anne
hidalgo à villeurbanne on y reviendra
dans ce match des idées puis il y à la
primaire écologiste
ça y est la liste des candidats est
officiel voyons qui se lance avec jérôme
rabhi ils sont les premiers à se lancer
dans les primaires les écologistes ont
arrêté aujourd'hui les candidatures pour
départager leurs prétendants à l'elysée
et ils sont quatre sur la ligne de
départ et yannick jadot est sans doute
le plus connu
eurodéputé il avait remporté la primaire
écologiste en 2016 avant de rallier
benoît hamon régulièrement testés dans
les sondages il plafonne sous la barre
des 8%
mais cette fois persuadé que ce sont les
écologistes qui mèneront une alliance de
la gauche à la présidentielle
delphine batho pourrait aussi être ce
trait d'union ex socialiste elle a pour
elle l'expérience d'avoir été ministre
de l'environnement sous françois
hollande
une ministre remercié pour avoir dénoncé
un manque d'ambition budgétaire pour le
climat présidente de génération écologie
elle sera la seule candidate non issus
de élevé à cette primaire eric piolle
lui a été un des premiers maires vers
d'une grande ville dès 2014 quand il l'a
emporté à grenoble
réélu facilement en 2020 il défend la
création d'un arc humaniste allant de
l'ancien marcheur matthieu orphelin aux
insoumis ancien cadre dirigeant dans
l'industrie il promeut un projet à la
fois radicale et pragmatique
sandrine rousseau enfin est la première
à s'être lancé dès octobre dernier
économiste engagé de longue date pour le
climat elle défend une écologie
féministe
la principale inconnue du scrutin réside
dans le nombre de votants à cette
primaire car pour 2 euros et la
signature d'une charte
n'importe quel français de plus de 16
ans peut s'inscrire jusqu'au 12
septembre
le premier tour aura lieu du 16 au 19
septembre et le second tour du 25 au 28
septembre
les candidats ont pris l'engagement de
soutenir celui ou celle qui s'imposera
dans ce scrutin est avec nous pour ce
match des idées en direct ce soir pierre
jacqmin bienvenue rédacteur en chef de
la revue regards
thor de ce livre ils ont tué la gauche
et mickaël d'armes en face à vous bien
sûr éditorialiste politique chez europe
1 et vous publié en octobre prochain je
crois le souverain c'est bien ça
merveilleux merci à tous les deux donc
ça y est première primaire de cette
présidentielle qui est donc lancée je
répète le nom des candidats delphine
batho et yannick jadot eric piolle
sandrine rousseau
est-ce qu'on a quatre lignes vraiment
différente là michaël darmon
on a quatre intentions quatre chambres
de légitimité différentes mers ancien
ministre est lui élu local donc deux
régions ont députés eurodéputés donc de
ce point de vue là on est sûr gérer un
panel de ce que représente aujourd'hui
la légitimité politique de des
écologistes après on va voir dans quelle
mesure le rituel je dirais d'une
primaire écologiste dans une fois de
plus se confirmer c'est à dire que très
souvent il ya une tentation d'éliminer
donc ceux qui sont en pole position ou
qui sont considérés comme pouvoir
rassembler parce qu'il ya toujours une
la tentation quand même de dire il faut
ses membres confirmés en permanence le
socle donc idéologique et on va voir
dans quelle mesure effectivement il peut
y avoir une dégradation surprise parce
que les écologistes qui sont toujours la
première primaire du processus nous ont
toujours surpris donc de ce point de vue
là il faut s'attendre effectivement à ce
qu'ils envoient la première la première
indication personne n'avait fait
attention à l'époque au fait que cécile
duflot avait été vraiment sérieusement
éliminé dégager de la primaire dont
écologie ça préfigure est également une
campagne à l'époque très attendue donc
on va voir effectivement ce qui va se
passer là maintenant vous la voyez avec
crainte cette primaire pierre jacqmin ou
pas avec voilà des candidats qui
se déchirent qui essaye de ne pas
offenser mais se divisent quand même
avec des lignes qui se démarque très
fortement il faut la craindre cette
primaire j'ai plutôt un bon souvenir la
primaire écologiste qui avait eu lieu en
2011 si ma mémoire est bonne et qui
avait donné lieu à des débats
intéressants et qui montraient qu'il y
avait une diversité effectivement et des
lignes pas de fracture mais des lignes
et des sensibilités différentes qui
s'expriment et chez les écologistes qui
va être intéressant c'est que comme la
primaire est ouverte puisque il faut
participer on peut s'inscrire dès
aujourd'hui je crois sur le site de la
primaire écologiste en ligne et payer
une cotisation soit deux euros pour
pouvoir voter en septembre ouvre le
champ c'est-à-dire que si ça avait été
seulement les écologistes enfin les
militants d'europe écologie les verts et
des autres partis qui participent à
cette primaire qui avait été en capacité
de voter sans doute le jeu était pas
fait mais pratiquement c'est que on sait
que quand même les écologistes ont sont
plutôt favorables à l'ailé gauche de
donc plus tôt eric piolle ou même
sandrine rousseau parce que sans les
rousseau est une candidate qui aimait
par les militants à l'essai une
candidate féministes qui s'est fait pas
tout qui s'est fait connaître par un
combat que contre denis baupin donc à
l'accusé de violences sexuelles elle a
gagné son procès elle savait peut être
comme ça donc se relancer avant les
autres elle s'est lancée la première à
s'être lancée effectivement elle a un
programme elle a en projet elle est
celle qui parle avec les autres gauches
la france insoumises du parti socialiste
des partis communistes
donc allez allez était en tout cas je
pense allez disons favorite chez les
écologistes mais comme la primaire est
ouverte effectivement tout le monde
toute la gauche presque même peut-être
la droite pourrait être tenté d'aller
voter et choisir le candidat qui serait
le mieux placé pour ne pas faire de
l'ombre aux autres candidats je crois
qu'il ya une ligne assez intéressante
entre ces quatre candidats je pense que
je disais tout à l'heure que sandrine
rousseau eric piolle était plutôt
identifié à la gauche des écologistes et
c'est vrai que yannick jadot même si
c'est lui qui est peut-être le plus
connu aujourd'hui qui a le plus la place
dans les médias et qui a le plus de
notoriété vous dit pas ce qu'il a
annoncé sa candidature sur tf1 et que
c'est pas donné
c'est une chose mais c'est aussi celui
qui a donné des interviews il disait oui
ne disait pas ce que l'histoire des
écologistes raconte la rupture avec le
capitalisme lui il n'est pas forcément
sur 7 sur cette ligne-là la question du
marché il est il est un il est un
économiste presque libéral presque à
tendance j'aurais tendance à dire que il
aurait presque envie de faire ce que les
allemands ont fait serre qui il a
toujours cette volonté d'assumer une
forme de crédibilité jusqu'à allait
rentrer dans le match dans le jeu
contemporain du libéralisme ce qu'ont
fait les allemands faisant d engouement
des alliances avec la droite je dis pas
que amy jade haussé son projet il a dit
il a toujours dit qu'il était un homme
de gauche
mais on sent quand même qu'il ya cette
ouverture à vouloir rassembler très
largement ce que ne disent pas eric
piolle et laissant des fonctions qui eux
leurs familles est clairement identifié
la gauche et les écologistes du coup il
est peut-être plus présidentiable aussi
et oui mais avant d'être prises en ciel
il faut être désigné par son parti
on en a connu beaucoup de bon président
mais qui n'ont pas pu être candidat donc
il faut d'abord passer cette étape et
c'est vrai que l'enjeu là pour cette
primaire clairement et yannick jadot
c'est vrai le l'incarnent complètement
sellal à la conversion possible à une
forme de réalisme liés à la pratique
politique lié au pouvoir au fond si
encore si on se réfère à l'histoire de
la gauche ce serait un petit peu voire
et intégrer ce que ce que rocard et le
rocardisme ont apporté à la culture de
gouvernement d'une première gauche donc
il rien peut-être le besoin d'une 2e
peut-être écologie certains appellent ça
aux détracteurs parfois des années que
jadot appelle ça le l'écologie de marché
pour pouvoir justement être capable de
d'englober les tenants et aboutissants
d'une de politique publique lorsqu'on
est au sommet de l'est pas parce qu'au
sommet de l'état c'est aussi être
responsables là des gse être responsable
de l'armée
responsable de politique étrangère faire
des eaux font des choix qui ne sont pas
toujours identifiés par une approche
donc de la pensée de la pensée
écologiste aujourd'hui donc c'est
l'enjeu et c'est intéressant parce que
c'est toujours la question quand on veut
aller vers le pouvoir
quand on veut rassembler des millions de
français quel est ce qu'il faut pas
aussi être capable pouvoir faire des
concessions par rapport à sa propre
famille politique
une fois de plus les écologistes seront
au pied du mur d'autant plus qu'ils ont
des élus locaux nouveau des mers depuis
paris ce mal qui ont fait parler d'eux
et justement je sépare donc il m'est
revenu que rich iott a été assez
impressionné par le résultat des
régionales parce qu'ils considèrent que
le il faut de la leo le recul qui a pu
avoir il y est aussi aux prises de
positions très clivante des des mers
après leur élection et que ça refroidit
les électeurs donc il ya cette réflexion
qui existe est ce qu'il faut vraiment se
passe au convertir une forme de réalisme
pour rassembler oui 12 est question de
la primaire est ce que c'est
potentiellement une machine à perdre
parce que si toutefois cette même si
elle est un petit peu ouverte si
toutefois les militants désigner une
personne comme eric piolle ou sandrine
rousseau qui sont quand même plus des
écologistes plus radicaux disons cela
comme ça ce sont potentiellement des
jeunes qui nous enfin pour lesquels les
français l'ensemble des français ne
voterai pas moi je
j'ai le sentiment qu'ils vont poser dans
le débat public un certain nombre
d'idées de propositions et dont les
français vont sans doute s'empare et
j'espère qu'ils vont avoir une audience
et une surface pour pouvoir faire
avancer leur lors leurs idées les uns et
les autres et de montrer aussi quelles
sont leurs différences je crois pas
qu'ils aient beaucoup enfin même si
effectivement j'ai parlé de lignes de
fracture tout à l'heure je pense qu'ils
vont aussi faire le nécessaire pour que
à la sortie de ces primaires il ne soit
pas divisé qui soit en capacité de se
rassembler encore est-il encore faut-il
d'ailleurs que les uns et les autres
acceptent le verdict de cette primaire
moi ce qui m'intéresse ça va être le
discours des uns et des autres visages
de la gauche puisque il se revendique
encore de gauche et que l'enjeu pour les
uns les autres et j'ai entendu encore ce
week-end y avait le festival des idées
qui a rassemblé l'ensemble de la gauche
et des écologistes où chacun cherche à
dire c'est autour de moi que doit se
faire l'union et on doit porter une
seule et unique candidature qui doit
être écologiste à l'élection
présidentielle
donc c'est l'après primaire une fois que
le candidat va être désigné quelle va
être la main tendue vis-à-vis de la
france insoumise vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste qui semble avancer vers une
candidature aussi vis-à-vis du parti
communiste français qui est lui-même en
campagne donc ça va être leur capacité
aux uns et aux autres aussi à pouvoir
dialoguer avec de l'ensemble des forces
ya l'élection présidentielle mais il ya
aussi la capacité de cette gauche et les
écologistes à créer une opposition où
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
puisque après l'élection présidentielle
il y aura les élections légistatives et
donc je pense que la personnalité qui
sera choisi par les écologistes
l'ensemble des mouvements écologistes
qui participent à cette primaire ça va
être leur capacité individuellement à
porter un projet collectif et donc
peut-être effectivement faire des comme
ça a été le cas original lors ses
contours des alliances sur la base de
compromis de consensus que j'espère les
mois les moins qui me remettent en moins
en cause les projets des uns et les
autres en tout parce que pendant qu
europe ecologie les verts lancent son
processus de désignation candidats en
2022 anne hidalgo elle travaille à un
projet pour la france avec ses soutiens
rassemblés à villeurbanne
ne lui dites surtout pas qu'elle est
candidate à la présidentielle pour
l'instant anne hidalgo alors avant d'en
parler avec vous sur ce plateau on va en
parler avec l'un de ses soutiens qui est
donc sur place bonsoir patrick kanner et
merci d'accepter de répondre à nos
questions ce soir dans ce match des
idées je rappelle que vous êtes
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
ce rassemblement a déjà commencé il ya
quelques heures si je ne me trompe pas
est ce que vous sentez qu'anne hidalgo
franchi un pas supplémentaire vers cette
candidature à la présidentielle avec ce
rassemblement qui ressemble très
clairement je suis très heureux que je
lui ai remis il ya quelques dizaines de
minutes
un exemplaire des 500 premières
créatures des élus de de france
hexagonale et ducrocq maire donc
demander à quelles se présentent à
l'automne prochain donc les choses se
mettent en place le mouvement se crée le
projet était beaucoup travaillé
aujourd'hui autour de thèmes de la santé
de l'emploi de l'écologie donc
nous allons apporter notre pierre à
l'édifice et bien entendu le débat
précédent effectivement aujourd'hui nous
avons des des lignes parallèles
notamment avec les écolos faudra bien
que ça converge parce que sinon le
principe de réalité par conrad et aucun
de nos candidats présents au second tour
que tu quand même pas le but de mon
élection présidentielle encore un mot de
l'anecdote ce que vous nous racontiez
patrick kanner quand vous lui avez
apporté ces signatures qui at elle dit
pourquoi dites vous que ça y ressemble à
une future candidature à la
présidentielle pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les d'algoé dans une
phase de construction
dans la tête je pense que les choses
vont très très très fortement évolué
mais la question n'est pas d'être dans
une aventure individuelle alors je sais
bien qu'on peut croire à l'homme ou la
femme providentiel et providentiel
l'élection d'un cinquième au public mais
c'est pas du tout ça à sa manière de
fonctionner voilà elle veut un travail
collectif et pour ce travail collectif
soit utile c'est bien il faut très
concrètement que cela s'accompagne de la
construction de son projet donc elle est
dans cette phase de construction
politique de ces propositions n'a fait
d'ailleurs plusieurs tout à l'heure lors
de son discours de conclusion qui
n'était pas un discours de multiples
mais le discours de la conclusion d'une
journée de travail donc on n'est pas du
tout dans la même tonalité donc cette
étape de villeurbanne est pour moi un
cailloux blancs supplémentaires dans la
perspective de sa candidature qui si
elle devait se confirmer ce avec le
rabbin à l'automne et je crois que
carole delga y est également présente un
dans ce rassemblement patrick anr est ce
que vous sentez une dynamique autour de
cette présidente sortante et réélue
magistralement de la région occitanie
oui tout à fait
quand le gars a accepté d'être un peu
l'accord de la triche cette plate forme
de travail politique qui s'appelle plus
d en commun gens qu'elle fera de fait
entre lui et la présidente d'une future
association et c'est très bien que bon
j'avais bien lu dans la presse l'idée
que oui car au t4 et carole delga se
rangera potentiellement dans les
couleurs dans la foule
le jour venu comme énormément d'élus
vraiment des grands mères étaient
présents aujourd'hui pour représenter
les deux présidents de groupe
votre serviteur mais aussi valérie
rabault était présent l'idée fort cette
partie était là
il y à une tente de convergence
aujourd'hui qui se manifeste autour de
la candidature de potentiel encore une
fois d'anne hidalgo
j'ai envie de 10 ans prend une métaphore
très lié à l'actualité spatiale qu'on a
connu hier
là cela on est en train de d'avancé
la fusée vers le pas de tir et
villeurbanne a été peut-être pour le
premier étage de cette fusée est resté
avec nous patrick nro si vous le voulez
bien on va discuter un petit peu en
plateau de tout ce que vous nous avez
dit ce soir et je vous donnerai la
parole peut-être dans un instant si vous
avez le temps dites le nous évidemment
si ça pose un souci pierre jacqmin bon
c'est un secret de polichinelle elle va
y aller année delgo finalement oui je
sens dans la voix de patrick anr
beaucoup de volonté beaucoup de dents
vie derrière la candidature de mme
hidalgo et c'est vrai chez beaucoup de
militants socialistes je crois que la
candidature d'annecy algo fait envie
elle a été élue maire de paris et bien
réélu malgré l'absence la part de la
participation
je crois que les français attendent en
projet sur tout et et dans la voix
d'anne hidalgo on n'entend pas encore
véritablement ce projet alors certes un
projet ça se construit visiblement c'est
ce qu'il se passe j'entends patrick
kanner nous dit que cette candidature
est possible elle n'est pas encore
totalement actes et même s'il vient de
dire que dit carole delga se rangera je
le cite se rangera derrière anne hidalgo
le moment venu donc on voit bien que
toutes et à tous tes est enclenché le
comité des élus locaux avec la crise
cette tribune en faveur d'hamid à gorron
tu sens que tout ça est quand même bien
calculée ou en tout cas étant mais
plutôt bien engagées ou bien préparé je
crois qu'il d'algos anne hidalgo a un
profil clivant pour de bonnes et de
mauvaises raisons elle a un profil
clivant à paris pour les raisons que
beaucoup de français connaît sur la
question des transports sur la question
de sa volonté son sa détermination aussi
à lutter contre la pollution sonore la
pollution aussi environnemental ça c'est
un premier point puis elle est cliente
aussi plus largement dans la société
peut être aussi à gauche et chez les
écologistes on l'a vu c'est la première
à avoir tiré contre les écologistes en
les accusant de ne pas savoir exactement
quel était leur rapport à la république
donc je pense qu'anne hidalgo 6
la gauche et les écologistes ont cette
ambition de porter une seule et unique
candidature est peut-être celle d'anne
hidalgo elle entend que rassembleuse il
faudra qu'elles puissent aussi
s'adressait à l'ensemble des autres
formations politiques dont elle a déjà
dit qu'elle exclue et de son chant la
france insoumise
alors qu'elle fait partie des
composantes de la gauche presque
traditionnelle j'ai envie de dire ils
ont des projets qui sont pas forcément
et nécessairement très éloignés on l'a
vue régional julien bayou clémentine
autain audrey pulvar qui était la
conduite d'anne hidalgo étaient sur une
même liste ils ont fait campagne
ensemble alors certes les propositions
d'une région sont pas les mêmes que
l'échelle nationale mais je pense que
anne hidalgo devra aussi envoyer des
signaux forts envers la gauche et les
écologistes si elle veut être
rassembleuse maintenant il va falloir
aussi voir quel sera le projet et si ce
projet est en capacité de faire
regrouper les autres formations
politiques autour d'elle c'est prévu ça
un signal fort aux lèvres la france
insoumise patrick anr en france à celui
à son propre candidat et n'envisage pas
entend seulement de le retirer mais
aussi les enfants d'âge aujourd'hui
commence à atténuer le rôle potentiel de
jean-luc mélenchon
non c'est moi je crois au rapport de
force en politique les français ont
déterminé un rapport de force l'équipe
hôte élections départementales et
régionales
nous sommes redevenus une force centrale
non mais juge unique mais une force
centrale non pas parce qu'on s'est
arrogé sept fonctions et c'est plate
mais parce que les français nous ont
donné sept places au travers de leur
choix même si malheureusement ils ont
été trop peu nombreux à voter
donc moi je suis intimement convaincu
intimement convaincu que la démarche des
meneurs go à une démarche bien sûr
d'abord d'affirmation il faut affirmer
que cette candidature est souhaitable et
souhaitée en france et deuxièmement il
faudra bien sûr ensuite rassemblé bien
évidemment nous non plus de tranquillité
avec les mouvements écologistes qui
avaient que d'autres d'autres mouvements
très très concrètement elle te dis
simplement mais on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui pour challenge et le duel
annoncé entre le pen et au macumba
il faut être au moins 18 19 20 % c'est
l'objectif qu'il faut succès et cela
dans l'union et au rassemblement
michaël darmon c'est intéressant parce
qu'au fond ce que l'on comprend c'est
que
ainsi que c'est ce qu'on fait on sait
que harry l'algo est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les écologistes à deux
titres
d'abord parce que la maire de paris qui
a pratiqué durant tout son mandat une
politique de transformation massive
en ce qui concerne et là la circulation
en ce qui concerne les choix de me
demanda et de d'action de politiques
publiques écologistes qui ont considéré
en bouleverser la vie de la ville et qui
a permis aussi sa réélection ça c'est un
fait et de deuxième fête c'est celui
d'aujourd'hui le dispositif politique
auquel on assiste à vie normale à côté
d'elle lie à carole delga qui a gagné
parce qu'elle n'a pas fait alliance avec
les écologistes mais avec personne et
parce qu'elle a réaffirmé le comme bien
de l'entendre à l'instant chez patrick
anr l'après la rep la nouvelle
présidence à nouveau du parti socialiste
par rapport aux écologistes puisqu'on
entend bien les thermes depuis quelques
jours les écologistes sont considérés
comme étant force émergente mais pas
force motrice donc bien évidemment
depuis le soir et de d2 2e tour des
élections régionales le le revirement le
plus spectaculaire étant solide olivier
faure qui encore il ya quelques semaines
laissé entendre qu'ils pourraient ne pas
y voit peut-être des lecteurs de
grondines des candidats socialistes à la
présidentielle et qui en une soirée a
totalement tourné casaque qui a
réaffirmé le primat comme on vient
d'entendre à l'instant du rapport de
force ce fameux rapport de force
installons santis a gagné parce qu'elle
n'a pas fait d'alliances et il a voilà
symboliquement aux côtés de aux côtés
d'anne hidalgo et ans très certainement
pour l'opposition dans sa campagne et
étant je dirais le la vitrine ou
l'étendard du dispositif politique qui
ait pensé donc sa home ça augure de
tension je dirais et de difficultés
extrêmement importante pour arriver à
une union
reste que ça reste que les sondages mais
elle peine effectivement à découvrir et
à décoller effectivement gagné parce
qu'il n'est pas fier à lédenon c'est
vrai mais c'est un paradoxe parce qu'on
voit dans l'élection que ce soit les
élections municipales où les élections
effectivement régionales les socialistes
en sortent plutôt dollar et inversement
le parti de jean luc mélenchon la france
insoumise on peut pas dire qu'ils aient
fait de très grands scores atp
inversement dans les sondages jean luc
mélenchon est quand même celui qui fait
la course en tête se fasse aux candidats
de jado anne hidalgo qui sont testés je
crois qu'à fait fait partie de ces
candidats aussi qui reste pour la
majorité des français il nous conduit à
parisienne assez parisienne d'ailleurs
c'est pas sans lien avec le coup de
communication qui a été celui de anne
hidalgo dans paris match où elle se
montre en pleine nature avec la campagne
a choisi villeurbanne
vas-y ville a effectivement donc on sent
cette stratégie de vouloir essayer de
faire en sorte de coller aux français de
ne plus avoir cette image de parisienne
qui ne se préoccupe que des soucis des
parisiens est reagan est d'être un
dernier mot sur ces sondages c'est vrai
qu'ils ne sont pas vraiment favorable
anne hidalgo disons le we fall et ses
éléphants d'âge on a vu qu'ils ont été
démenties très largement au directeur
départemental
je pense qu'aujourd'hui à l'idéal go et
sondés alors qu'elle n'est pas encore
candidate elle n'est pas encore
candidate jour elle sera candidate je
pense qu'on pourra en reparler très
largement
et puis les sondages voilà il faut il
faut les contredire au travers de
l'action menée est donc aujourd'hui à
villeurbanne que d'une première étape
encore une fois voilà on a aujourd'hui à
une petite année pour montrer que c'est
encore possible et que la gauche soit
présente au second tour dans cette
élection présidentielle merci beaucoup
patrick kanner je reste merci infiniment
d'avoir été avec nous peut-être encore
un mot mais quelle d'un oui une
villeurbanne s'est effectivement penser
comme étant une caisse de résonance et
un test pour savoir si effectivement à
hidalgo peu où sa voix peut dépasser les
frontières parisienne et s'installer
comme étant une voie dans l'ensemble du
pays ou en tout cas des forces de gauche
ou des socialistes c'est le test on
verra le résultat
il nous reste quelques minutes et on est
maintenant un petit peu plus d'une demi
heure d'une
l'intervention présidentielle je vous
vois évidemment faire l'amour puisque on
les aime plus beaucoup ces interventions
présidentielles elle annonce en général
des mauvaises nouvelles
que faut-il en attendre d'après vous à
pierre jacqmin je pense que chacun va
écouter attentivement le président de la
république j'espère que compte tenu de
ce qui vient de la séquence qu'on vient
d'ouvrir avec de l'airé triste les
restrictions qui ont été élevés vont pas
nous on nous conduire vers de nouvelles
restrictions maintenant j'en ai pas
personne n'est dans la tête des
d'emmanuel macro ni même des médecins et
de ce qu'ils recommandent qui font des
recommandations emmanuel macron c'est
d'ailleurs la seule question comme moi
qui m'interrogent qui m'interpelle c'est
que j'ai le sentiment qu'on n'a pas tenu
les leçons de l'année et demie qui vient
de se passer je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'ils large concertation là jusqu'en
large consultation à la fois des élus
locaux à la fois des parlementaires à la
fois des syndicats aussi je crois pas
qu'il y ait eu encore une fois c'est ce
partage de données on a entendu j'ai
entendu l'institut pasteur nous
expliquer que à ce rythme-là de
vaccination l'immunité évidemment ne
sera pas du tout satisfaisante en
septembre mais que donc sans doute
faut-il prendre des mesures dès
maintenant je ne crois pas que ce soit
en allant vers le terrain de
l'obligation ou de l'obligation de la
taxe de la vague de la vaccination pour
les personnels soignants ou même pour
l'ensemble des français qu'on va y
arriver je pense qu'encore une fois il
faut faire de la pédagogie il faut
arriver à convaincre qu'il faut
continuer à faire tout ce qui est dans
possible de l'état et de la machine
gouvernementale en tout cas de la
machine de l'état pour ramener les
dispositifs de vaccins pour que les gens
puissent se faire vacciner facilement
pendant leur lieu de vacances ou au plus
proche de chez eux ça reste la bonne
solution et il y à moi aussi un un doute
que j'ai sur cette espèce de culpabilité
qu'on ferait porter aux français alors
que l'ensemble des épidémiologistes
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
nous explique ça n'est pas qu'une
stratégie à l'échelle nationale qu'il
faut avoir
il faut arrêter de se regarder le
nombril quand on est les pays européens
les plis les pays riches les pays du
nord on sait très bien que l'immunité
doit être mondial s'il n'y a pas
d'immunité mondial c'est la reprise des
vaccins c'est la reprise des variants
qui part derrière donc il faut aussi se
préoccuper de tous ces pays du sud qui
manque de vaccins qui ne parviennent pas
justement à vacciner leur population
week end
le public voulait s'adresser aux
français cette période de l'année pour
dire la page est tournée et on va
pouvoir ouvrir une nouvelle séquence il
obligé de parler aux français pour dire
la page n'est pas tournée et on va
continuer à se préoccuper de ce qui va
se passer demain on va aller
vraisemblablement vers une après les
informations qui nous remontent vers une
un durcissement de mesures en
particulier de l'élargissement du
passani terre à l'ensemble des
établissements publics qui va
effectivement créé les tensions et
soulever les débats que vous évoquez
c'est à dire effectivement qui ceux qui
sont pas rentrés dans les catégories une
housse on ne pourront pas participer à
cette à cette vie publique dont c'est
une manière de reprendre des
restrictions quant à elle a
effectivement l'obligation de vacciner
de vacciner les personnels soignants ou
autre et dans pompiers étaient en
contact avec le public et bien ce sera
la décision qui va être annoncé
mais hier les acteurs gouvernementaux
nous disait qu'on allait
vraisemblablement vers cette voie
on va voir si c'est avéré et je vous
remercie infiniment tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ce match des idées
27 aele pl en direct mais on se
retrouvera à 22h30 pour un nouveau
numéro spécial autour de cette
intervention du chef de l'état qui se
déroule donc maintenant dont environ 35
minutes que vous allez pouvoir suivre en
direct sur notre antenne dans le cadre
d'auditions publiques à qui je donne la
main maintenant à tout à l'heure
[Musique]